يبدأ كل عام بأفضل
النوايا لتصبح أفضل ما لديك ولكن
وفقًا لقصة 2015 من US News
and World Report ، تفشل 80٪ من قرارات السنة الجديدة
بحلول الأسبوع الثاني من
فبراير ، تقول الجمعية الأمريكية لعلم النفس
إن هذه الأشياء الخمسة يمكن أن
تتحول إلى صراع  إلى النجاح ، ابدأ أولاً بشكل
صغير ، بعد هدف واقعي ،
على سبيل المثال ، إذا كان هناك المزيد من التمرين ، فإن
قرارك يبدأ ببضعة أيام في الأسبوع
بدلاً من سبعة تغيير تالي
لسلوك واحد في كل
مرة ، وقد يكون الحديث عن ذلك كثيرًا في وقت واحد أمرًا مربكًا ،
تأكد من العائلة  يعرف أصدقاؤك وأصدقاؤك
أهدافك حتى يتمكنوا من المساعدة في الانضمام إلى مجموعة
مثل فصل تمرين أو الاجتماع
مع الآخرين الذين يقلعون عن التدخين يمكن أن
يساعد أيضًا في نجاح الحل ، ولكن إذا كان
لديك زلة لا تضغط على نفسك
ببساطة تعافى من الخطأ واحصل على
عد إلى المسار الصحيح أخيرًا اطلب الدعم لا
تواجه ضغوط الوصول إلى أهدافك
بمفردك في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
ماندي جاثر